so you're going to college for the
either back ecology or been the military
okay the number one out of the gate
crush it
that's what you should do in college you
should crush it you should study hard
and you should crush it now in order to
do that you got to get a mindset because
guess what you're gonna be thinking you
get out of the military may be like oh
this is no big deal and all this does
this doesn't matter like hey I was in I
was in Iraq eight months ago I was in
Afghanistan six months ago and now
you're sitting here tell me to read a
book and write down words on a piece of
paper this doesn't matter mm-hmm that's
an easy that's an easy path to go down
mmm it's pretty easy said you know why
because it's actually true and what you
did in combat has more gravity and more
consequence than anything you're going
to do in college and if you want to go
down that path and be this stuff doesn't
matter this isn't important compared to
what I've done so I'm gonna blow it off
that's a path you can go down if you
want to I don't recommend it what I
recommend you doing is straight up
crushing college that's what I meant
recommend you doing how do you do that
because it everybody if you make that
decision that you want to crush it if
you want to make the decision that
you're gonna prove to people that you
know what yeah I was overseas I was in
combat now I'm coming back and your
little games that you're playing I'm
going to beat you in your own games so
how do you do that number one do the
reading that you get assigned do the
assignments that you get tasked with do
everything let that be your new job
these silly little games that they're
Plett them be your job like I'm talking
about OCS we're on to OCS I made that
like a game for me that I was going to
win so do that with college and then on
top of that make it a game yes but then
on top of that as a deeper commander's
intent make it that you're going to not
just do well there as a game but you're
going to do well so you can get smarter
you can really actually learn
information that's gonna make you a
better person and give you better
ability to dominate in the world that's
what you should be doing in college now
these kids that you're gonna be going to
college with they're not going to have
this attitude they're gonna be you know
hey what do I need to do to get by
what's sali doing tonight I'm more
concerned about that than I am about
going out dominating this course so that
I can get an A so that I have knowledge
so I can go and crush some some vocation
later on in life so don't just do it as
a game you got to play the game a little
bit I mean you got a gap for me I get
the game mentality going but I'm the
game mentality is rooted in something
deeper and what it's rooted in is
gaining knowledge to be smarter and
better as a human now a couple things
about college and the actual tactics
techniques and procedures to dominate
because when I went to college I did
dominate and when I went to high school
I did not dominate when out of high
school I didn't care about high school I
was like whatever god when can I go in
the military right kick it when can I go
now so but when I went to college I had
a new attitude which was I'm gonna
dominate I mean I'm in a battle against
these people here I'm gonna meet them so
this is some of the things that are
important number one college is all
about time management getting ahead of
the curve because it's so easy that's
what happens with kids in college that's
why they don't do well because for the
first time there's no one tracking them
no one's imposing discipline on them you
have to have in order to do well in
college you have to have self-discipline
because no one's going to tell you to
start that paper that's due in six weeks
no one's gonna tell you to start it
tomorrow you know you know you can just
blow it off you can blow it off for five
and a half weeks and then you've got to
write a 30-page paper in two days and
it's gonna it's not going to be quality
yep no one can ask you have you done
your homework before dinner that's right
so you need to get the time management
going you need to get a discipline time
management schedule you need to get
ahead of the curve as early as possible
right you know when you want to know
papers do a 30 page
paper do you need to write in chunks and
it makes it so easy I mean it was a joke
when I was going to college I would have
my papers completely done like a week
out like a week out I would be done with
a 30-page paper and then I would just be
reviewing it and getting it all
completely dialed and I'd turn it in two
days early and then but move on to the
next one
same thing with studying you don't want
to study you do want to study hard right
before the day of the test but you want
to have knowledge already absorbed in
there so you want to we want to study
leading up to that when you do reading
that I talked about highlight break out
the highlighters that's what I do in all
these books that were hammering through
right now you know I always send out
pictures um they're all highlighted and
marked up and that's how I'm getting the
good information out of them so
highlight and then another little trick
is to make the flashcards I used to
highlight and then I would make
flashcards about what I highlighted yeah
turn everything into a question and then
you go through the flashcards and you're
gonna you're gonna memorize stuff hmm oh
here's the big one this is really
obvious but guess what people don't ask
questions ask questions I used to raise
my hand stir I would sit in the front
row first of all in college i sat in the
front row I was 20 I was a 20 I think I
was 27 or 28 years old going to college
I would sit in the front row in a little
desk and I look like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and like a little kids
day ID then I'd raised my hand all the
way up like all the way up over my head
and they'd be looking at me you know cuz
in college they kind of stopped raising
their hand but I did it anyways just to
be be you just be yeah just just to do
it
so I'd raise my and but you ask
questions because guess what the college
kids they don't ask questions and and
guess what adults don't ask questions
why don't they ask questions they had an
ego they don't want to look stupid it
you know I don't care no I mean I want
I'm here to win exactly oh I owe you
don't think I'm smart let's check out
the GPA homeboy
you know I'm zan so ask questions if I
didn't ask questions as soon as that
assumed is the knowledge as soon as the
understanding train starts to
derailed a little bit ask the question
right then maybe give it maybe give it a
minute to see if you can get it back on
track by yourself but the minute you
realize you're not understanding raise
your hand and say hey you know what
teacher I don't understand that can you
relay that because I'm not understanding
yeah you don't wanna miss the train I
don't want to miss the train you don't
want to go too far off course and then
you're just lost you know so when you
feel it coming off try and catch up real
quick you can take a look and then just
raise your hand put your hand all the
way up in the air sit in the front row
put your hand all the way up in the air
and look at the teacher with with a dead
serious face and they're gonna look at
you all nervous and be like yes yeah
yeah that's the only one I went to
college they called me John because
because that's what the attendance sheet
said because my real name is John and
that's a key attendance sheet said and
so they'd be sitting there and they'd
say yes John and I'd say yeah I don't
understand that could you reexpose
hey when they called you John did that
fuel the fire no not at all it's it
doesn't matter to me but it's the only
time because like I didn't know these
people because normally if I'm gonna
work with someone when I introduce
myself I'd be like hey my name is Jacque
because that's what everyone always
calls me but these people would call my
name in attendance and I didn't want to
have this you know
adversarial release yes I saw yes John
that's me the other thing is you know do
some psychological warfare you know I
would line up my pencils I do it on the
podcast you Bowl right here I line up
pencils it's a it's a it's also getting
into character right you're priming yes
I'm priming myself I'm looking at the
teacher like I am so ready to take notes
that if I have a downed pencil it will
not cost me a single letter I'll be back
in the game are your contingency yeah I
continue to festas are standing by and
then so I sit in the front row line up
your pencils have your notebooks ready
personally challenge the teacher you
wanted to you want your personal
challenge to be to pull every piece of
knowledge out of them and then go beyond
what they know I was I was I was
competing with the teachers I was trying
to learn more than they actually do it
and then they bring their little test
rule exams you and you just crush them
and smash
now the thing you gotta be careful of
here is this can get political this can
get political and if you start being
offensive with the way you act if you
start rubbing it in their face then
guess what that can affect your grade
and part of the game here is to get a
good grade so you actually it's a time
for you to start building your
relationship building skills time to
start building your leadership skills
because you're gonna start manipulating
the teacher right you want to make them
think that you're actually super
interested in those stupid crap class
that they're teaching I want them to
think that not out now some classes
you're gonna love they're going to
you're gonna learn a lot from like if
you're into English and you get to take
advanced grammar and syntax you're going
to be sitting there like yes this is
rocks but there's me some classes you
don't want to take but you got to get in
there and make your teacher think that
you're super interested in super fired
up to learn that thing and that you're
not just interested in the grade but at
the same time they got to know that
grade is important do you do so you want
to get along with them and again go into
college and if you're a veteran you
representing all of us out there so you
should be going in there and just
smashing college